the first Israeli cabinet meeting after
a Palestinian gunman killed seven
Israelis outside the synagogue on Friday
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu said
his government was not seeking an
escalation but the decision announced
afterwards such as the opposite
we will step up the deployment and
activity of the security forces we will
exact a price to those who carry out
terrorist attacks and their supporters
we decided to revoke the National
Insurance rights of families that
support terrorism including revoking
identity cards and residency of families
of terrorists that support terrorism
but human rights groups say some of
those decisions constitute Collective
punishment against Palestinians as they
are Target not only the alleged
attackers but also their extended
families
Israeli forces have already sealed off
the home of one suspect's family in
occupied is Jerusalem after Netanyahu
promised a serious response hours later
Israeli bulldozers demolished a family's
house there that family has no known
connection to the attack on Friday
there hasn't been every warning the kids
woke up screaming as they saw Israeli
soldiers covered with heavy weapons and
dogs with them at least 13 family
members are living in this house we were
confused about what to move out of first
when they came
on Sunday funerals were held for those
killed in the attack outside the
synagogue on Friday
that happened a day after an Israeli
raid in the occupied West Bank killed
the nine Palestinians Israeli forces
have killed 31 Palestinians since the
beginning of this year the Israeli
military is deploying additional troops
to the West Bank that has seen months of
worsen and violence the Israeli Army is
also increasing its forces in occupied
is Jerusalem the Israeli cabinet has
also decided to Fast Track issuing
weapons permits to thousands of Israeli
civilians a decision that concerns many
Palestinians there is no sign yet that
the Israeli government is preparing for
a full-scale military response to the
shooting on Friday with U.S Secretary of
State Anthony blinken visiting Israeli
and Palestinian leaders this week they
were expected to contain violence but
now with the most right-wing government
in Israel's history and growing
grievances from both Palestinians and
Israelis the situation is unpredictable
resource Al Jazeera was Jerusalem